PROSECUTOR FULTON COUNTYROF DON
ENTIAL
LET'S GET
MURRAY.
Ror
HEOFVE NEW COURT FILING IS
SPIGATION INTO R
EFFOS TO OVERTURTH  IN THE STAT
GEORGIA.
THIS IS RERA
APRIL, AND EARLIER IN THIS
IGATIOHERNEY HAD SAID ALL 16 OF
THESE FAKEOR TARGETS
AS PAR PROBEE CLS G THIS
SCO TRTOIFICATION OF THE 2020
ENTIAL ELECTIO
NOW S GOA W ND
COOPERATORS ON HER.
THISS PART OF ON WE'VE
THIS DELAY OR TENSIO
EXTENSION INN GOING TO
BRING TH
SHE WAS LIKELY TO MAKE
ANNOUNCEMENT O
THEY ARE GOIO  GETTINGRMATION F
ANYONE TG CHARGES AGAINST CASE.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY HAPREVIOUSLY
THESE FAKE ELECTORS
BEGINNG TO TUR EACH OTHER
AND INCRIMINATE EACH.
AN ATTORNE EIGHT
SUGGESHE TURNINGEACH OTHER OR
INCRATING EVIDENCE, BUT
TH B BRING IN ELLI MEACALLY THE
IMMUNIT
>> SO IMNIWERFUL
TOOL PROSECUTORS CAN
TESTIMONY FROM PEOPLE WH
FISSUES A  OR REQUESTS
RECIPIENT O
AI FORS
IS T OKAY, WE'RE NT. GOITOSE
>> BUT THEY'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
OFN LAWMAKER
LAWMAKS  OA LIKE RUDNIACO VOTINI
TIHINEEO
THEY'RE LOOKING ATHL DONALD TR
MADE TO THE GEORGIA SECRETARY OF
STAS CALLS TRUMP
MADE TO OTHER GEORGIA  THEM TO
L E  STRATEGY
RIGHT W AT TYPE OF
TRY FACETH P
TRYING TO CLIMB THLA E
USE E TESTIMONSE FAKT ALSO I TH
O MOVE UP E CHAIN OF
COMMAND HERE.
UE
ATTETIO INTERFERE WITH AN  COOR.
ONEVIOUS REPORTING AT PROSECUTOM